hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
the notion of metaphor plays a very
important role here in the theory that
Nietzsche is setting out in this essay
on truth and lying in an extra moral
sense why is metaphor so important well
you know in one part he's going to say
that truth itself is a mobile army of
metaphors metonym so he goes on and
medon UM's are closely related or
metonymy is closely related to metaphors
and metaphor is city as a matter of fact
you could say that a metonymy is a
special sort or subclass of metaphors
although some theorists try to
distinguish them apart from each other
for Nietzsche metaphor is going to lie
at the very basis of what it is that us
human beings do by virtue of our
intellects and when we think about you
know what the intellect enables us to do
part of it has to do with concepts
grasping those manipulating them
identifying things as falling under a
certain concept and then you know
perhaps deducing or or at least arguing
or inferring to to some important
conclusions but language itself was
identified early on by the Greeks you
know for example Aristotle as being
something that that is also key to human
beings and this you know the rationality
of concepts and intellectual life and
that of language were connected with
each other
Nietzsche is saying yeah they're
connected with each other all right but
they're connected with each other
precisely in such a way that a little
bit of lying goes on all the time and
the lying goes on in the way that we use
language even the way we coin language
and the way we use concepts it's
constantly taking place as a matter of
fact you could say that the metaphor is
really what is foundational for
Nietzsche rather than than truth or even
lying everything can be a metaphor and
then you know there is of course the
issue aren't you being metaphor it's
metaphorical and saying that
and Nietzsche would embrace that and say
exactly
I am so let's take a look at what he's
he's saying he says think about what
goes on with words right unless we're
willing to settle for truth in the form
of tautology
we're always exchanging truths for
illusions what is a word the portrayal
of nerve stimuli in sounds but to
conclude from a nerve stimulus to a
cause outside of ourselves is already
the results of a false and unjustified
application of the law of causality
we're going to talk about that and in a
different area these these laws and then
he says what would allow us if the truth
of the origin of language the viewpoint
of the certainty of terms were alone
decisive what would allow us to say the
stone is hard as if hard were known to
us otherwise than by a subjective
stimulation some sort of nerve stimulus
he is saying here we arranged things now
notice what he's saying we arranged
things by genders this is a function in
in German of course but also in most of
the other indo-european languages he
says we we designate the tree in German
der bomb as masculine the plant the
plants ax as feminine and he says what
arbitrary transferences and we could
think of many other features of our
language in English gender really
doesn't play that much of a role except
when we're talking about ships as she or
things along those lines but we have
many many equally arbitrary ways of
talking about things don't we some of
which we inherited actually from our you
know sort of Germanic heritage but some
of which corrupt their weird way in
through Latin or Greek or French or all
all sorts of other things you know for
example we from the German heritage we
we inherited these strong verbs swim
swam swam right now what the hell is
that about well there's there's this you
know umlaut at takes place and and
verbal you know changes of the vowels
denoting you know some difference in
time there's a whole interesting story
that can be told there but it seems
rather
arbitrary doesn't it the language use so
he goes on and he says we don't grasp
things in themselves what we grasp are
things as we make sense of them so he
goes on and he says the creator of
language designates only the relation of
things to men and to express these
relations he uses the boldest metaphors
now when we talk about metaphors in in
most cases we are thinking about
language right and we're talking
typically about you know here's one
definition of metaphor plate putting one
thing in place of another I am a bear if
I have not had my coffee in the morning
I'm not literally a bear you know we can
make it the kind of metaphor that we
call a simile I'm like a bear if I don't
have my coffee in the morning same sort
of sense you're substituting bear with
its certain qualities for for me right
or we can talk about Aristotle's got
some great you know examples of
metaphors that he's taking from the
poets in his rhetoric you know he
compares for example a shield to a cup
right how are they similar they're round
you know so you can talk about the cup
of Ares for example or you can talk
about the shield of Dionysus and you're
transferring one thing to another so
there's this one thing being placed in
place of another and there's also a
transference of something is it a
transference of meaning is that a
transference of sense in language we're
usually talking about meaning and
connotation but we're also talking about
relations right when we use that famous
metaphor of a face that launched a
thousand ships did Helens face like
somehow you know get down there and push
each ship off the shore no it drew them
like you know like like you know magnet
to you know a piece of iron again a
metaphor right we can't really get away
from these and
our foundational for us nature says now
he goes a little bit beyond the realm of
language to encompass other things so he
talks first about he says first he
designate it translates a nerve stimulus
into an image first we have an object we
have a nerve stimulus coming from it and
then we have some sort of image and he
says that is the first metaphor then the
image must be reshaped into a sound a
word this is a second metaphor so
already we've got metaphor going on by
the time that we even get to language he
says at and each time there is a
complete overlapping of spheres from one
sphere to the center of a totally
different new one we're going from
different domains from nerve stimulus
which is in one domain to image which is
in another domain unconnected to it but
actually we make the connections and
then to sound which again it doesn't
have to be connected to it it's each of
these is almost like its own world but
we squish these worlds together and push
one thing from one world into the next
and connect them all up into things that
make sense for us so he goes on and he
says when we speak of trees colours snow
and flowers we believe we know something
about the things themselves although
what we have are just metaphors of
things which do not correspond at all to
the original entity the nerve stimulus
is closer to the object the image that
we have is closer than is the word but
it's further away than the nerve
stimulus the word itself is as far away
from it as we can possibly get we can
even have words talking about words and
then it gets really complicated doesn't
it like when we talk about metaphor what
is a metaphor like it is one thing in
place of another or a transference we're
already engaging in metaphor in doing
that and that nature goes on and he says
let us think about the formation of
concepts what makes a word into a
concept well when it's supposed to refer
not just to one thing but to a whole
bunch of
things that are supposed to be similar
in some respect right so we form mental
concepts of for example paper right
here's a paper
here's another paper here's another
paper right and here we go
a whole bunch of heat purrs that are all
paper and what do we do
Nietzsche says he says that we overlook
the real and the individual and not
because we just sort of forget about it
we're doing that as integral to the
formation of concepts is that like you
could bring that back into the concept
that is what what it means they have a
concept that overlooking that
abstracting away so he goes on and he
gives you some examples he says just as
no leaf as ever exactly the same as any
other certainly the concept leaf is
formed by arbitrarily dropping those
individual differences by forgetting the
distinguishing factors and this gives
rise to an idea that there is something
in nature that is a leaf independent of
us and that this leaf we might call it
leaf capital L is somehow the same and
all the things that we call or observe
or conceptualize as Leafs this is all
metaphorical according to Nietzsche
though he has another example of a
person as you know we say that a person
is honest we have why did he act act so
honestly today our answer usually goes
because of his honesty and he says we
know nothing of an essential quality
called honesty what we know are numerous
individualized hence two similar actions
which we equate by omitting that is
similar and referring to them as honest
actions last of all we formulate out of
them a quality occulta that means a
hidden quality with the name honesty and
it's it's really by overlooking the fact
that we engage in this overlooking that
we're able to think that our concepts
and even our words are referring to you
know classes of objects that are all the
same
then just have some accidental
differences if we want to look at it an
Aristotelian way or if we want to look
at it and nature's sort of almost yet
Antipodes with Plato here in saying that
what's real are these these things and
they're all individual things and then
we are the ones who create things like
archetypes or patterns or forms of them
and that is a metaphorical rather than a
reality producing or reality
you know orienting way of doing things
so metaphor is intrinsically connected
to language and concepts and it's by
forgetting the fact that metaphor is is
actually fundamental that we start to
think that language and concepts
describe a world that's truly out there
being named being conceptualized by us